today's topic sharon osborne after
defending pierce morgan she got into a
discussion with
cheryl underwood which i'm not gonna lie
to you guys i didn't even know the talk
was still happening after i watched that
clip many years ago with the cutting off
of the pinore i didn't know the show was
still happening it was the episode man
definitely so i really would like to
know because i've been knowing you for
years
i've been here and i've never seen
anything come out of you other than
if i don't know i'm willing to learn if
it comes off a certain way i
stand corrected right that's the only
thing i've seen so what would you say to
people
who may feel that you while you're
standing by your
friend it appears that you give
validation or safe haven
to something that he has uttered that is
this even even if you don't agree am i
am i saying it right
i don't know what he's uttered that i'm
not
i'm not trying to slide out of this one
right i don't know
tell me what has he uttered that's just
i
feel even like uh i'm about to be put in
the electorate chair because i have a
friend
who many people think is a racist so
that makes me
resist and for me at 68 years of age to
have to turn around and say
i ain't just what's it going to do with
me
how can i be about anybody
how can i be raised about anybody
or anything in my life how can i
well well i will watch we'll be right
back we have more
it's like you're asking you're asking
well you know
tell me but you're clearly not willing
to know tell me yeah what what
that's not i don't want to tell you this
is what i'm saying i know these
conversations can be difficult and i
know sometimes you could feel someone
just trying to lob things at you
but sometimes you got to take yourself
out of it just to listen a little bit
further so let's just see what happens
i've been asking you during the break i
am asking you again
and don't try and cry because if anyone
should be crying it should be me
okay all right okay okay this is when
you go full on karen because from what
i've
gathered she's being very common trying
to talk you through it she's not being
aggressive i've seen when people
try to try to railroad people off the
road be like you're right i've seen that
this is not that's not what happened
this is not that
i think you're in your feelings and
you're getting really heated and you say
you don't have chill ma chill
this is the situation you tell me where
you have heard him say
educate me tell me when you have heard
him say
things educate me tell me i think
there's something unhealthy about just
running up to people like
but i also think there is something to
be said about the fact that like just
because i feel a certain type of way
provided i'm not being aggressive
towards you and screaming at you i don't
always have the obligation to show you
how you're wrong
sometimes i just want to go about my day
that doesn't mean i'm bad you're a
racist and walk away i generally don't
do that
but if there's like people saying this
stuff you have also a little bit of
responsibility to try to do a bit of
that research yourself
it is not the exact words of
racism it's the implication
and the reaction to it to not want to
address
that because she is a black woman and to
try to dismiss
it or to make it seem less than what it
is that's what makes it
but but right now i'm talking to a woman
who i believe is my friend
and i don't want anybody here to
to watch this and say that we're
attacking you for being and and that
and and for that if i articulate it
see she didn't she wasn't listening she
heard for me
and she just felt attacked this is when
you place your feelings
over the entire discussion i understand
it could be triggering or it could get
you
but you got to make that effort to
listen and to just try to be slightly
objective about this because she's just
like
she's already looking off already we
don't want to attack you but
yeah like you said she felt attacked and
the thing is that cheryl
i believe cheryl is doing a great job of
trying to like hey listen
we gonna decipher things so what it is
is
what you actually asked for sharon you
asked for this
right and cheryl is actually doing a
freaking good job
blaming you no listen it's not exactly
what he said
but it's this and that and that and
everything but you're so
busy not listening to what she's saying
as a black woman
putting herself in the place of another
black woman
and showing you that perspective you're
so busy not listening
something that you asked for that it's
irrelevant whether
what you said or not just throw it all
in the trash it doesn't matter because
you're not listening thinking anything
late i think that's already sewn but
that that is why i'm saying for me
i'm saying for me for me i thought i was
asking
a question about the perception for
other people that's why i prefaced it
with
i've never heard you utter anything else
but i have but i have felt
that pierce was in his stance
against meghan markle and the last time
he was on this show
i said as much i said it when
he was on this what was his answer to
you he didn't feel that he didn't feel
that it was
he didn't feel that that the the racial
statements that he was making were
this but i was talking to him okay
answer me this one
okay because i don't know i don't
understand
if he doesn't like someone and i think
this
is for everybody who isn't
born white if he doesn't appears doesn't
like someone
and they happen to be black
does that make him arrest no no
that's a no no right it's not just the
fact that he doesn't like her
it doesn't stop there if it was just the
then that would be one thing then you
rely on the facts he doesn't even rely
on the facts that's why i notice in the
conversation if i have to go back to
what i said and be like
i thought what i said was a question
which was
a question if i have to verbalize that
to someone that i'm talking to
and go back to everything that i was
saying
and explaining it back to you it's just
that's a clue
that you were not listening at all
because i have to reintroduce what i
said hey listen
remember when i said with the question
mark at the end
i was just asking the question it was
not an attack that's because you were
not listening the first time
you just got triggered and that's
another proof that she's not listening
yeah
people always say like i'm coming here
to listen and oftentimes they're not
willing to admit that they could be
wrong
the possibility they're not even open to
that this is the kind of conversation
that makes a lot of minorities feel like
i don't want to have to have this
conversation i'm trying to educate you
because i don't really believe you
trying to listen because she's handling
it
as best as i've ever seen someone handle
a racial discussion she's not even
accusing the person across from her
but this person is so triggered and
being such a karen in that moment
that she can't take the time to
understand if you're not willing to
recognize ladies the ways in which you
could be
a messengerist or men could recognize
the ways will you be
misogynist like if you're not willing to
have these conversations and be open to
listening to
you don't have them but don't pretend
either that you're trying to listen and
learn
a lot of people just want to go to
imright.com
hear an opinion that reinforces their
belief and then feel great
but i got black friends and they never
talk to me about that maybe they don't
want to
because they know you they don't want to
have that conversation with you because
you're not willing to
listen because people really oftentimes
they mix up
hearing and listening hearing is just
you're saying word and i heard what you
i heard you said something
listening you actually have to ponder
and reflect about what the person said
and that's not what's happening right
there
you know what and you know right now
shows on hiatus recently i think some
other guy
um some black dude made an interview
with sharon where she could tell all and
then he started tagging like
black creators on instagram and i think
sometimes
when it comes to these things they'll
oftentimes prop up a black person to do
an interview to make it really
good from a pr standpoint but i think
when it comes to this discussion like
it's not always our job to teach you
about this stuff and to
tell you you know like if you claim
you're willing to listen and we've made
an effort and you're not willing to hear
us
at some point you got to go do your own
research because it becomes exhausting
to try to tell people hey man you did
this wrong and they're not
interested in hearing you that's the
time so i'm like yo if you don't want to
tell them you don't have to
i get it you know in the past i've said
like guys if you're not going to educate
like what
sometimes it could just be tiring
sometimes people just don't want to hear
it so i'm just like you know what
i'm just gonna abstain from this entire
conversation
because it's a waste of time now i see
how you roll and i'm gonna move on with
my day unfortunately sharon wasn't
trying to learn
but you know when it comes to what
pierce says like if you don't see the
racial undertones if you think that
protecting the royal family is more
important than having this dialogue
about
you know the real reality of what we say
to people who have children
who are dark you know the the
conversations around skin tone and stuff
like that the problem was that
inherently in what pierce said the fact
is that he disregarded anything that
could be true about megan because
it appears he has a personal problem
with it i'm not defending wagon i'm not
doing this like peers like i don't
believe
that she had a mental breakdown and
anything that how would you know
anything that has to do with the queen
he's gonna protect the queen by all
means so therefore
he has his biases if you silence people
or try to silence people or try to
mitigate their um you know their ability
to speak or
if you essentially with no because
you're a journalist with no proof
whatsoever
try to discount someone's uh testimony
no proof
as a journalist just because you want to
defend the queen you know and if it
relates to
racial things considering the history of
the monarchy and all that stuff i could
definitely see how people would call you
100 do i believe he is not necessarily
i don't know but there's a real
discussion to be had the fact that
sharon's being like oh my god i'm just
like
this whole thing was weird but like i
said that's all i had